[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
dimanche en politique sur france 3
bourgogne franche comté les violences à
l'encontre des femmes ont augmenté de
22% en 2010 7 par rapport à 2016 et
chiffres tout aussi inquiets tant en
2016 en france une femme perdait la vie
tous les trois jours sous les coups de
son partenaire ou ex partenaire les
récentes affaires médiatisées en
bourgogne franche comté viennent
d'ailleurs nous rappeler que ces
violences vont parfois très loin trop
loin
comment lutter contre les violences
faites aux femmes comment prévenir cette
situation comment entendre les alertes
des femmes en détresse
on en débat ce matin avec nos invités
marie mercier bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice les républicains de saône et
loire vous avez été rapporteur de la loi
schiappa au sénat est ce que ça veut
dire marie mercier qui lie à un
consensus dans la classe politique
aujourd'hui sur ces questions oui je
pense qu'il ya un consensus sur la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
peut-être que dans la répression pénale
là on a des divergences mais en ce qui
concerne la protection des femmes bien
évidemment on y reviendra bien sûr
marivin dit bonjour vous êtes écrivaine
et présidente de solidarité femmes 21
une association qui accompagne les
femmes victimes de violence entre autres
est-ce que vous aujourd'hui
j'allais dire vous prouver sous les
appels c'est à dire est-ce que ça a
vraiment changé depuis quelques mois bah
c'est ça correspond aux chiffres on a à
peu près plus un peu plus de 20 % de
demandes par rapport à la sphère enfin
mis tous
en tout cas c'est de ces derniers et
sept dernières années c'est au moins
plus de 20%
donc ça correspond à cette parole qui se
libère olivia colomès bonjour je vous
est avocate et vous avez défendu
plusieurs femmes victimes de violences
devant la justice sept ce chiffre en
augmentation on a du mal à savoir si
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise nouvelle
pour vous c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
la simple et bonne raison qu'à mon sens
les femmes s'expriment peut-être plus
facilement aux exprimé ose parler de ce
qu'elles vivent et de surtout de ce
qu'elles subissent et crois au fait
qu'on peut peut-être les aider et mettre
fin à leur calvaire
on va en parler durant toute cette
émission bien sûr merci à toutes les
trois d'avoir accepté cette invitation
au plateau quasi exclusivement féminin
même si j'avais invité le directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique du
doubs qui n'a finalement pas pu nous
rejoindre avant de vous donner la parole
mesdames je vous propose de revenir sur
ces événement très médiatisé de ces
derniers mois qu'ils nous ont donné
envie de réaliser cette émission qui
sont autant de signaux d'alert sur ces
situations vécues par des femmes en
bourgogne franche comté avec françois
latour le 30 octobre une femme de 34 ans
d'origine afghane est tué en pleine rue
dans un quartier résidentiel de besançon
razia est tombé sous les coups de
couteau d'un homme de 38 ans son mari
est le principal suspect
mère de trois enfants elle fuyait un
mari violent elle avait porté plainte à
sept reprises et étaient hébergées à
besançon dans un foyer d'accueil pour
femmes victimes de violence conjugale en
juin 2010 est elle déposait sa première
plainte pour violences aggravées
le mari de razia l'avait ensuite menacée
de mort à plusieurs reprises elle avait
obtenu une ordonnance de protection en
juillet 2010 8 interdisant à son
ex-conjoint d'entrer en contact avec
elle rafid askari interpellé le 2
novembre à athènes va être extradé vers
la france
en franche-comté un vendeur une femme
est morte sous les coups de son
compagnon
le mois dernier à dellys à 21 ans est
retrouvée inconsciente dans son
appartement
les secours alertés par le concubin qui
explique avoir tué sa femme l'emmène au
chu où elle décédera de ses blessures
le couple était parents d'une petite
fille de 13 mois un délice à travailler
comme caissière dans un supermarché et
était apprécié de tous
le compagnon de la victime 23 ans a été
mise en examen pour meurtre sur conjoint
et écroué
leur petite fille a été placée sous la
garde des services sociaux déduits
octobre 2017 le corps d'un homme d'une
soixantaine d'années est découvert par
les gendarmes sur la commune de la khl
est en saône et loire
la femme de la victime indiquent avoir
enterré la dépouille
valérie 36 ans a abattu son mari d'une
balle dans la nuque en expliquant être
passé à l'acte
suite à de nombreuses violences viols et
après avoir été contrainte à se
prostituer
des faits confirmés par le procureur de
la république
placé en détention provisoire elle a été
libérée fin septembre 2018
aujourd'hui placée sous contrôle
judiciaire elle vit dans un lieu gardé
secret jusqu'à l'ouverture de son procès
fin 2019 marivin dit ce sont des cas
j'allais dire extrême parce que il ya
l'histoire terrible de ces femmes finit
par une mort par un homicide
est-ce que cependant sont des choses qui
auxquels vous êtes confrontés
régulièrement
ce sont des cas extrêmes mais
d'un extrême mais qui arrive quand même
tous les deux jours et demi tous les
trois jours sur le vent les années donc
par exemple par rapport à la sphère
razia je crois que la veille deux femmes
sont mortes en france
donc possiblement assassinées par leur
conjoint ou ex conjoint
donc voilà c'est presque c'est pas tous
les jours c'est tous les deux jours et
demi mais voilà c'est à la fois
extraordinaire parce que les violences
elles sont elles sont aussi différentes
elles sont quotidiennes les violences
dans le couple n'aboutissent pas et fort
heureusement à ces extrêmes mais
néanmoins on est quand même force est de
constater que ça arrive régulièrement on
peut pas dire autre chose
olivia colomès ces cas de figure là ils
sont la fin d'un long calvaire souvent
vous avez eu à défendre des clientes qui
étaient victimes de violences
oui bien sûr c'est évidemment la fin
d'un long calvaire mais c'est parce que
l'ajustement lie à l'acte de trop mais
on il faut arriver à des violences
extrêmes pour que finalement la justice
se saisisse et que véritablement de
puisse protéger ces femmes
mais en amont et c'est surtout là la
difficulté que rencontrent les avocats
c'est lorsque l'on reçoit des femmes qui
sont victimes de violences comme ça au
quotidien violences physiques mais aussi
psychologiques surtout peut-être même
psychologique on arrive tout doucement à
leur destruction les on les pousse même
parfois commettre l'irréparable
et là on est un petit peu démuni face à
la justice parce que les textes de loi
manque pour justement réprimer ce genre
de comportement au quotidien puis on a
toujours ce sacro-saint problème qui est
celui de la preuve je voudrais vous
poser justement cette question
concernant les violences qu'on parle de
violence de quoi est ce qu'on parle
quand on parle de violence là qui sont
peut s'adresser d'ailleurs à toutes les
trois
m bah violence sapaient les violences
physiques évidemment les coups portés à
son conjoint ou je vais vous donner un
exemple hier geste et donc je rentrais
après le déjeuner mon cabinet et dans la
rue je vois un couple qui commence à ce
cri mutuellement l'un sur l'autre et
tout d'un coup ils arrivent vers elle et
lui crache à la figure en pleine rue à
14 heures comme ça et si vous voulez là
il n'y a pas eu de coups ya pas eu de
violence elle n'est pas blessée mais là
c'est une sacrée violences morales vous
imaginez une médiation pieds là on était
en pleine rue donc je ne veux même pas
imaginer ce que cette femme qui subit
dans en vase clos
lorsqu'elle est à son domicile avec
accent conjointe marie mercier on a
choisi d'appeler cette émission violence
point le mauvais genre point
d'interrogation est ce que quand on est
femme aujourd'hui en 2018
on en est encore là oui malheureusement
je crois qu'on en est encore là et que
la violence c'est quelque chose
d'exposants ciel qui commence maintenant
presque dans les cours de maternelle
dans les écoles primaires au collège
avec des jeunes garçons violents des
petites filles violentes également la
violence chez les adultes c'est
peut-être un peu différent moi je trouve
que la violence elle arrive à son
paroxysme quand l'autre ne résiste plus
et quand on n'a plus cette notion du
respect du respect du corps mais aussi
du respect moral de l'autre et quand ans
quand cette forme de harcèlement va
ensuite jusqu'au bout c'est à dire
jusqu'à la destruction totale et comment
contenir ces violences
bien évidemment il ya un arsenal
législatif qui est là mais je pense
réellement que toulon je sais dans la
prévention est donc dans l'éducation par
exemple au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale aussi quand vous avez eu à
légiférer sur la loi schiappa par
exemple vous étiez confronté à deux
types de violence parce qu'il ya aussi
tout le pan du harcèlement du
harcèlement sexuel etc des violences
sexistes qui sont pas forcément des
coûts par exemple mais qui n'en reste
pas moins des violences dont il ya
vraiment deux chantiers de front est ce
que c'est lié est ce que est ce que pour
vous c'est le même combat
c'est le même combat parce que souvent
l'auteur ne se rend même pas compte de
ses actes
il n'a pas la pression finalement que ce
soit si mal que ça que ce qui fait jour
après jour à bout c'est grave non elle
prend tout mal où il prend tout mal il
ya cette hiérarchie qui n'existent pas
parce que les valeurs n'ont pas été tout
simplement expliqué de ce respect dont
nous parlait tout à l'heure on a des
fois des des idées reçues sur les lieux
où les où les conditions sociales des
personnes qui sont victimes de ces
violences ou coupables de ces violences
marivin dit est ce que est ce qu'il ya
un portrait robot de la situation où est
ce que vraiment ça touche toutes les
couches de la société
sa couche ça touche absolument toutes
les couches de la société tous les âges
tous les milieux toutes les professions
donc ça c'est
so lu ment certains il est vrai que
c'est plutôt des milieux plus modestes
dont on a accès en fait plus facilement
parce que se mêlent aussi avec les
problématiques de violences parfois des
problématiques sur les enfants donc il
ya peut-être des signalements ou voilà
et peut-être c'est plus cachés dans des
milieux aisés ou la honte est encore
peut-être encore plus forte
voilà mes mais néanmoins nous on sait et
on le voit c'est vraiment tous les
milieux confondus disait il ya il ya un
problème dès le départ dans les cours
d'école je suis tout à fait d'accord et
c'est vraiment alors il ya toute la
chaîne à revoir et à discuter et
réfléchir mais le premier maillot icc
vraiment l'éducation c'est l'éducation à
l'école parce que faut pas qu est ce qu
on dit à ses enfants on leur dit la
fille l'atteindront de la frapper parce
que c'est une fille quand même pas non
on dit pas ça mais ça c'est notre
société qui est profondément patriarcale
encore aujourd'hui et ça se voit dans
les cours de récréation ça se voit dans
la manière dont on a vu que les petits
garçons et dont on éduque les petites
filles et on le fait souvent
inconsciemment c'est à dire que moi même
mois engagé etc je suis pas sûr d'avoir
élevé tout à fait pareil mon fils et ma
fille et mon fils ma fille et mon fils
pardon même si on essaie de faire les
efforts c'est très ancrée dans notre
société on demande aux petites filles
d'être attentif d'être douce d'être pas
trop jt d'être poli on investit encore
aujourd'hui et malgré tout les garçons
pour qu'ils soient sportifs un garçon
qui remuent êtes un peu bagarre voilà un
peu bagarreur
voilà ça c'est des choses qui vont qui
sont très très très très longue à bouger
et on a besoin des services publics
parce qu'on a besoin de l'éducation à
l'école pour pallier aussi ce qui se
fait pas dans les familles c'est à dire
aussi les jeux qui sont proposés les
manuels scolaires enfin bon c'est quand
ils mettraient ajouterait un problème de
vocabulaire
les enfants très souvent non plus les
mots et au lieu de s'exprimer par la
parole mais il se tape
parce que finalement que ce soit dans
leur milieu où que ce soit à l'école
n'engrange pas suffisamment de parole et
de mots différents à mettre sur leur mal
être
donc il frappe il nous faut physiquement
de s'exprimer on évoquait il ya un
instant aussi avec marie mercier la
question
de cette évolution de la société et de
cette libération de la parole est ce que
concrètement vous pouvez tout les trois
répondre à cette question est ce que
cette augmentation qu'on voit dans les
chiffres
à quoi selon vous allez du il ya une
chose qui est sûre c'est que les femmes
sont mieux informés et elles toutes les
émissions qui sont faites les numéros le
39 19 et c'est mon tout cet arsenal fait
que les femmes ont un petit peu moins
d'appréhension peut-être à dénoncer l on
accepte être plus facilement aussi aux
informations de l'augmentation donc ça
c'est certain mais on à lever des tabous
aussi bas je sais pas on peut pas aller
jusque là
non non non non c'est voilà c'est aussi
une partie du problème c'est que les
tabous ils sont encore là voilà et puis
une chose aussi
par contre que je maîtrise pas moi je
pense j'ai la sensation mais je m'appuie
juste sur mes émotions mais on est dans
une société aussi de dix paires violence
parce que deux on veut une satisfaction
immédiate et cédera fin ces affaires là
c'est aussi les affaires d'intolérance
profond dans la frustration aussi bien
chez les petits chez les grands chez les
adultes
voilà il faut que ça aille vite il faut
qu'on soit satisfait et je pense que
c'est aussi une partie du problème
marie mercier vous diriez qu'il n'y a
pas d'augmentation des faits de violence
c'est simplement une prise de conscience
et une libération de la parole ou est-ce
qu'il ya quelque chose dans notre
société qui rend qui rend les hommes ça
reçoit plus violent qu'il y a quelques
années c'est peut-être envie de dire les
deux certes les chiffres cachés et c'est
heureux ce chiffre augmente parce que
finalement les femmes vous vous libérer
leur parole des victimes vont libérer
leur parole en ce qui concerne la
violence dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
c'est indéniable c'est une société
je pense vraiment vraiment violente les
tabous mais c'est notre travail à tous
de lever ses tabous que ce soit
l'inceste que ce soit les l'éducation à
la maison avec des enfants qui vont
subir des violences sans pouvoir dire
que ces violences c'est la seule façon
qui connaissent eux cette façon là avec
laquelle ils sont éduqués donc ils n'ont
pas de comparaison possible
je pense que tout ça fait que la société
qu'on est en train de préparer
actuellement faut bien penser qu'il faut
toute une génération et que les jeunes
actuellement avant qu'ils soient qu'ils
remettent leur propre monde à l'endroit
il faudra tout se tendre qu'il faut pas
rater il faut pas rater cette
marche de l'éducation dès l'école
maternelle je vouvoyais réagir tout à
l'heure à ce que disait marie vallier
alors oui je suis d'accord pour ce qui
est de l'éducation malgré tout ça la
médiatrice l'a évoqué il ya une question
de 2,2 d'éducation aussi c'est à dire
que ce l'on sait très bien qu'on a
tendance à répéter ce qu'on a vécu dans
son enfance et les enfants qui ont été
éduqués avec dans cette ambiance de
violence j'incite physique tant physique
que psychologique ont tendance à répéter
l'histoire mais surtout oui
structurelles c'est pas culturelle c'est
vont régler ce qu'on a vécu
c'est ce qu'on connaît c'est sa
référence c'est la référence de ces
personnes là et il ya ce problème là et
il ya aussi ce second problème qui qui
fait que le modèle aussi c'est on se
tait on ne sort pas de la maison ça ne
sort pas du cadre familial
voilà bien sûr et alors ça c'est une
première chose il ya une seconde chose
qui me semble très importante et sur sa
cage et rebondir sama pouvait dire ma
voisine mais l'action de justement des
associations comme solidarité femmes 21
est primordial parce que moi je vois
dans mon cabinet des femmes qui
aujourd'hui la en dix ans a énormément
évolué et qui viennent me voir
et moi je me suis bien heureuse de
trouver des associations comme
solidarité femmes interne parce que je
vous garantis qu'à milan mais oui mais
il ya dix ans j'étais là en face de mes
clientes et je faisais mais comment je
vais j'ai pris des choses je vais
d'accord je vais écouter on va on va
déposer plainte
d'accord mais le temple enquête soit
menée le temps que les policiers ou les
gendarmes interviennent que le ministère
public décide procureur la république
décide bon on y va on l'entend quêtes ou
pas bah oui mais en attendant on est
toujours en danger la fin aujourd'hui
c'est ça alors qu'aujourd'hui je me pose
plus question et grâce à solidarité
femmes 21 france victime 21 et puis bien
d'autres mais surtout ce livre est la
femme d'un ter en amont et bunge appel
en j'ai un numéro m'est arrivé les
appelez moi même avec ma cliente en face
en disant écoutez j'ai une cliente là
s'il vous plaît trouvait lui de toute
urgence un hébergement d'urgence
communique son nom juste
parce qu'elle est en danger et il va
falloir qu'on lance une procédure
mais il faut absolument qu'on la sorte
de son de son milieu familial avec ses
enfants
souvent on la sort et l extirper de son
milieu familial avec ses enfants et ça
c'est grâce à l'intervention justement
il va sur ses alertes finalement ses
premières alertes que vous recevez on se
rend bien compte que sans que ça soit
forcément pris à la légère par certains
services c'est pas forcément pris à sa
juste mesure en tous les cas si je peux
dire les choses comme ça c'est certain
enfin on le voit et on voit très bien
dans la ferrade ya un moment donné il
faut quand même dire que il ya des
dysfonctionnements il ya des problèmes
il y a les choses s'améliorent nous à
solidarité femmes on prend en charge des
victimes et il ya une petite partie de
notre travail qui est aussi la formation
donc on le voit on forme des policiers
en forme des gendarmes on aimerait
pouvoir aussi former des magistrats des
avocats extra mais parce que là il faut
le dire il ya des choses qui ont évolué
et maintenant il ya des services
spécifiques dans certains endroits la
loi est passée par là aux est là et on
voit la différence à dire une femme qui
va être reçue par une personne qui a été
formé par un policier qui a été formé ou
un gendarme qui a été formé qui connaît
un petit peu la situation
voilà ça va être une chance pour elle
mais une personne qui est dans une autre
zone qui va tomber sur un autre individu
notre personne ne va voir l'individu
occasion peut ne pas voir peut ne pas
déceler le problème regardez ce qui
s'est passé avec la sphère razia nous on
était elle était avec solidarité femmes
25 25 à besançon elle était accompagnée
on est quand même une association
garante aussi de je dirais entre
guillemets la crédibilité d'une personne
c'est à dire vous prenez le temps de les
connaître l'association on était
conscient du danger et comme on l'a été
sur un certain nombre d'autres cas par
le passé c'est à dire un moment tous les
signaux s'allument on sait qu'il ya un
danger
donc là il faut quand même que il faut
quand même regarder où a été le problème
c'est à dire que cette femme elle savait
qu'elle était menacée et pas pour
rigoler la preuve
donc il ya bien eu je suis désolé mais
sabre à la dernière plate a pas été
reçue n'a pas été entendu alors la balle
est dans le camp du législateur si j'ose
dire marie mercier
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire parce
que on a on a beau lire les derniers
textes de loi le gouvernement
ne semble pas toujours avoir pris la
mesure je parle à quelqu'un qui est dans
l'opposition au gouvernement d' emmanuel
macron mais on n'est pas dans un sujet
d'opposition politique à proprement
parler est-ce qu'on peut encore aller
plus loin est ce que vous vous avez
envie par exemple au sénat de faire des
propositions dans ce sens bien sûr qu'on
a envie d'aller plus loin
est ce qu'il faut aussi bien comprendre
c'est qu'on ne part pas de zéro c'est à
dire que la loi elles existent déjà
on a une loi qu'on complète qu'on
amendes très souvent la loi elle est mal
connue mal appliquée tout notre travail
justement de coller aussi à la
constitutionnalité de façon à voter des
choses qui peuvent être mises en place
et ne pas être opposé une question
préalable de constitutionnalité ce qui
mettrait à bas tout notre travail je
veux pas me faire le porte parole des
dames qui sont en face de vous mais
j'imagine que et quand elles lisent la
loi schiappa pourtant dieu sait si
marlène schiappa est plutôt médiatique
et on sent que c'est un combat qu'il a
quelqu'un qui lui tient à coeur
on a l'impression quand même que c'est
très modeste par rapport aux problèmes
dont on parle
oui c'est à l'an passé parce que en fait
je pense que ce qu'elle avait dit elle
n'a pas pu l'écrire et le faire voter
parce qu'elle n'avait pas la possibilité
elle ne pouvait pas mettre en
application tout ce qu'elle avait promis
aux associations beaucoup il ya eu
effectivement là une très très grosse
déception et à juste titre ajusté une
femme violentée ce que nous voyons
d'hommes comme nous avons des des
appartements d'urgence mais ça ne suffit
pas il faut une prise en charge globale
d'une femme de sa famille de ses enfants
et ensuite quand l'auteur va sortir ce
qu'il faut c'est une prise en charge de
l'auteur de façon à ce qu'il soit
accompagné le but c'est pas nous il veut
faire de la prison il y aura une
répression pénale et c'est normal et
c'est juste mais il va ressortir quand
il va ressortir comment va être la vie
pour cette femme pour ses enfants il
faut que l'auteur du fils soit aussi
pris en chasse de façon à ce que son
éducation lui soir fait qu'ils
comprennent ce qu'il a fait pour le
remettre aussi dans dans l'humain c'est
cette sensation d'humains qui a été
perdu la loi elle aura jamais la
souplesse de la vie jamais on n'allait
pas s'en contenter de bien cerner à
mettre en place un arsenal mais aussi
des moyens
alerte je m'en a beaucoup parlé du
fameux téléphone etc
c'est parfait tout ça dans la loi c'est
écris tu ne voleras pas mais il ya quand
même des voleurs donc ce n'est pas parce
qu'on va écrire une loi qu'on va ça va
pas forcément faire peur je crois
beaucoup plus en l'éducation pour
véhiculer le respect il ya quand même
des choses à mettre en place vous comme
comme avocate est ce qu'à un moment
donné vous êtes confrontés à une forme
de processus se soient judiciaires ou d'
enquête qui qui qui va pas regarder ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure
heureusement je puis je peux m'adresser
et m'appuyer sur l'aide le soutien de
solidarité femmes 21 c'est à dire qu'il
ya une carence légal quelque part c'est
à dire que normalement si les choses
étaient parfaitement faites alors après
ça dépendra des tribunaux parce que j'ai
connu
j'ai exercé dans d'autres tribunaux que
celui de dijon et je me souviens d'une
réponse pénale qui était mais quasi
systématique et immédiate dans le
précédent tribunal qu'elle était
attachée et suffisait concours saisisse
le procureur et c'était le service de
permanence du procureur qui prenait tout
de suite la mesure il allait chercher la
personne placée en garde à vue est
organisée si besoin effectivement une
mesure d'éloignement de cette personne
avec placement interdiction d'entrer en
contact et c'est la victime qui rester
chez elle et monsieur qui allait plus
loin à charge pour lui organiser et ça
c'était pas tant mais le problème c'est
qu'on n'a pas d'uniformité d'un tribunal
à l'autre et ce que j'ai connu au
barreau de l'eau pour ne pas le citer
bas d'un petit peu moins réactif antonio
dans ce que je connais aujourd'hui je le
déplore je le regrette pas ce que j'ai
véritablement face de moi des femmes qui
sont désespérés paniqués qui peuvent
agacer certains certains policiers
certains gendarmes de temps en temps
parce qu'elle arrive et comprennent pas
pourquoi il ya une forme ça peut être
assimilé à une forme d'hystérie parce
qu'ils arrivent elles sont paniqués
elles sont mais elles sont pas elles
sont tétanisés et on n'a pas toujours la
solution à l'instant t et le problème
c'est que le danger subsiste voilà et on
a aussi cette difficulté je rebondis sur
ce que disait est là mais c'est la
triste tout à l'heure mais également le
lapray condamnation lapray sortie de
prison
j'ai une cliente qui m'a appelé
sam en une semaine dernière donc c'est
vraiment très récent on avait obtenu une
condamnation il est en détention
je ne sais pas pourquoi il ya eu un
petit homme qui quoique elle n'a pas été
informé de la sortie
sauf que moi cette cliente là il a
failli la tuer le jour
quand j'ai reçu ma clientèle sortait de
l'hôpital il y avait fracassé le crâne
avec battes en bois devant les
engagements il est frappé d'une
interdiction d'entrer en contact pendant
cinq ans la belle affaire
on n'est pas derrière lui il est pas
hélas pas le bracelet électronique
donc on ne sait pas où il va où il vient
et croyez-moi il a bien l'intention
annonce ans et je le crains de mettre à
exécution les menaces qu'il a proférées
moment le dur là il ya des choses à
faire c'est inacceptable que comme dit
mr en fait la loi et elle est déjà là
puisqu'il a interdiction de rentrer en
contact
la loi elle est là donc comment comment
faire pour que vraiment il ne rentre pas
en contact avec visiblement va pas bien
du tout cas pas l'intention de suivre la
loi a priori mais absolument donc toute
cette prise en charge qui doit avoir
lieu pendant que la personne est
incarcéré en fait c'est là où il faut
arriver à faire comprendre à l'auteur
des faits que mais que c'est qu'il est
inhumain c'est tout ce travail qui doit
être fait en prison et qui n'est
probablement pas passer c'est fait c'est
tragique ce qu'est ce que vous demandez
aujourd'hui comme association qui défend
les femmes victimes de violence aux
pouvoirs publics est ce qu'il ya des
actions concrètes qu'on peut mais qu'est
ce que vous dites à marlène schiappa y
est aux membres du gouvernement un moyen
de choses je suis absolument d'accord
c'est que la loi elle est là et dans la
loi ça devrait fonctionner on a
normalement l'arsenal à cela les larmes
et la peine de continuer à légiférer je
pense qu'à un moment donné il faut
plutôt se pencher sur comment faire
appliquer la loi et de la faire
appliquer partout pareil
plutôt que rajouter à chaque fois des
choses qui finalement complexifier le
discours et font pas avancer le problème
après quoi comment appliquons la loi
mais avec sérieux c'est à dire
exactement comme dit m colomès c'est à
dire quand une victime arrive paniqué
quand c'est agaçant pour les policiers
parce que elle revient elle elle enlève
elle retire sa plainte puis elle va
revenir
tout ça c'est des choses complexes donc
il faut de la formation il faut que les
gens soient info il
il faut que les gens soient bien formés
il faut que la loi soit appliquée de la
même manière je suis désolé mais vous
dites le la personne va en prison mais
la personne va pas très souvent en
prison moi je suis aussi chroniqueuse
judiciaire vous le savez donc je suis
très très souvent dans les tribunaux on
a quand même beaucoup de peine qui sont
des peine d'avertissement est ce qui est
très bien le but du jeu le but du jeu
est le but de l'association s'est pas
d'envoyer les gens en prison
et si je ne crois pas que ce soit
forcément la bonne solution parce que
justement en prison il se passe parce
qu'il devrait se passer mais néanmoins
quand la loi quand la justice donne
comme réponse un avertissement quand il
s'agit de violences quotidiennes de
violences répétées et oui à des dangers
pour moi il y a quand même aussi une
disproportion entre la réponse pénale
et là ce que vit au quotidien une
victime
donc voilà c'est ça aussi sur lesquels
il faut peut-être se pencher qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des auteurs de violence
comment les sorties à un moment donné
pour pour les mettre dans qu'ils soient
pas forcément la prison mais voilà pour
les contraintes déjà par exemple a
quitté le domicile tout simplement mais
là comme vous dites c'est c'est une
chose qui devrait être appliqué
systématiquement parce que nous on le
voit tous les jours c'est à dire qu'on
voit c'est les femmes qui partent avec
leurs enfants sous le bras en douce en
cachette et on leur dit préparer les
affaires avant
préparez votre départ parce qu'on sait
que le danger il est à ce moment là donc
c'est quand même on en est encore là
aujourd'hui
rite aid les coupables c'est pas
possible merci d'avoir accepté de
débattre ce matin je rappelle aussi que
dimanche prochain le 25 novembre c'est
la journée de lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes on aura donc sûrement
l'occasion d'en reparler merci d'avoir
accepté cette invitation et merci à vous
de nous avoir regardé dans un instant un
point sur l'actualité régionale avec
marie joly et puis la suite de dimanche
en politique parti national francis
letellier reçoit jacqueline gourault la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
locales
bon dimanche
[Musique]